prior to the start of the 2012 US
Championship and US Women's Championship
the club once again rolled out the red
carpet for the players all 22 players
were treated to a salon session many got
new hairdos and makeup they wanted to
look their best for the opening
ceremonies which were held at the
Missouri Botanical Garden we're kicking
off the 2012 US Championship and 2012 US
Women's Championship you know first and
foremost I want to welcome all of our
out-of-town guests the visitors the
competitors we really are thrilled to
have you in our city and we're so very
very proud to be the the chest city of
America but this would not have happened
if it were not for the tremendous
commitment and generosity of Rex and
Jeannie Singh field chief arbiter chris
byrd allowed players to come up one by
one and choose their locks they got to
see if they got more whites or blacks or
more blacks and whites
in addition the central west end was
proud to present a Guinness record the
world's largest chest piece is on
permanent display right outside the
world chess Hall of Fame and so I think
overall it's going to be a great week
with a lot of shots a lot of competition
hopefully the bus the made a better one
so come follow the action if you're in
the central west end the game start at
one p.m. Central 2 p.m. Eastern or
follow the action live at us chest
champs calm